mit schwerem gerät im sondereinsatz
florian berger fährt mit seiner
spezialtruppe in die sogenannten brot
müssten im bundesland brandenburg er
will die einwohner in der wenig
besiedelten region mit gutem brot
versorgen momentane bäckerei situation
in brand ist ernst
also immer mehr handwerks kleine
handwerksbetriebe die machen zu und
dadurch müssen sich die leute immer mehr
auf die discounter verlassen und das
brot vom discounter finde ich also nicht
besonders gut da muss man was dagegen
tun
heute geht es nach diesen zahlen die
kleinstadt nördlich von berlin hat knapp
6000 einwohner handwerklich gebackenes
brot ist trotzdem mangelware
ein fall für das brot höchsten
expeditionsfahrt zeug die mobile
bäckerei wurde zuvor in der armee
genutzt in der neutralen schweiz die er
nicht für ihre kriegerische art bekannt
ist
die schweizer hat 168 stück davon
ungefähr für jedes bataillonen der armee
eines und wollten damit die armee im
feld versorgen damit es natürlich nie
eingesetzt sondern haben immer nur damit
geprobt und die wurden anfang der 2000er
jahre wurden diese ganzen mobilen
bäckereien den kommissioniert und
verkauft und ich habe eben die nummer
130 bekommen
der platz im expeditionsfahrt zeug ist
optimal ausgenutzt
es gibt eine knetmaschine einen
wassertank und einen gasofen alles
andere ist handarbeit die mobile
bäckerei ist autark und könnte auch in
einer wirklichen wüste brotbacken
florian domberger sieht die nachteile
der engen backstube eigentlich als
vorteile für die mobile bäckerei geld
eigentlich klar ist es ungünstig dass
sie eng ist weil weniger platz heißt
weniger freiheit bei der arbeit aber auf
den zweiten blick ist es eigentlich sehr
interessant weil man gezwungen ist
effizient und effektiv zu arbeiten und
man denkt anders über handwerk nach die
deutsche brotkultur ist immaterielles
kulturerbe der unesco
mehr als 3000 verschiedene brotsorten
wandern täglich in den ofen
trotzdem gibt es immer weniger bäcker
die noch vollständig selbst backen in
den vergangenen 60 jahren sank deren
zahl von 55.000 auf knapp 11.000 große
ketten und auf backstationen füllen
diese lücke mit vorproduzierten zeigen
die künstliche zusätze enthalten
in florian demberg das brot kommen nur
wasser mehl und salz
das geheimnis ist der sauerteig die
geherinnen milchsäure bakterien und
hefen sorgen für den geschmack
würde ich mal sagen der ganz ganz große
unterschied dadurch gibt es mehr aroma
versorgung ist ein ganz anderes boot ein
ganz anderes leben florian dumberger hat
auch eine stationäre bäckerei in berlin
gelernter bäcker ist er nicht fast 20
jahre lang arbeitete er als logistiker
in australien der schweiz und asien
dort lernte er auch seine frau kennen
2015 beschlossen sie gemeinsam eine
bäckerei aufzumachen
es hat mich echt überrascht wie sehr die
deutschen ihr brot lieben
ich dachte nur wow wenn wir wirklich
eine bäckerei eröffnen wäre das schön
dann könnten wir zusammenarbeiten und an
das leben früher hat er allein die
brötchen verdient jetzt können wir das
gemeinsam als team machen das brot
wüsten expeditionsfahrt zeug ist ein
voller erfolg rund 70 bis 80 tage im
jahr ist es in brandenburg im einsatz
auf marktplätzen oder festivals auch im
wiesental kommt der frische service gut
an
der letzte becker der frische richtig
weg dennoch hat leider zu gemacht jetzt
von mehr als einem jahr das war sehr
schade
ansonsten gibt es noch hat die industrie
becker
wahrscheinlich gibt es
die deutsche wirtschaft kann
ohne konservierungsstoffe einfach
frische zutaten natürliche zutaten
regionale zutaten ist das beste was man
machen kann mit jedem einsatz in der
brot wüste kommt florian domberger
seinem ziel der gutes produkt für alle